[Musique]
Donald Trump a gagné le soir des élections.
Je ne veux pas voir
notre victoire électorale volée par
des démocrates de gauche radicale audacieux, ce
qu'ils font
et volé par les faux médias d'information, c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait et ce qu'ils font,
nous n'abandonnerons jamais, nous ne le
concéderons jamais.  n'arrive pas
vous ne concédez pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cette heure notre démocratie subit
un assaut sans précédent
contrairement à tout ce que nous avons vu dans les temps modernes
un assaut la citadelle de la liberté
la capitale elle-même
nous avons eu une élection qui  nous a été
volé c'était une élection écrasante
et tout le monde le sait surtout de l'
autre côté
mais tu dois rentrer chez toi maintenant
[Musique]
oublié